- Twitter's a controversial
place with a lot
of controversial opinions,
but let's see what they do
with medical info.
(person whistles)
Pew-woo!
Mela, my doctor thinks I'm hot.
He said fever, but I'll take it.
A fever is above 100.3 degrees Fahrenheit.
A lot of my patients come
in and say they have a fever
because they're running 99.5,
but that's not a fever,
technically speaking.
You are hot, though.
Mommy Cusses, found out
at my doctor's appointment
that the disturbing voices
I've been hearing nonstop
are called children.
(Mikhail laughs)
That's good.
Bill Murray.
Did Bill Murray tweet this?
I hate when I'm on the
treadmill and my hand
accidentally hits the stop
button, and I have to get off
and eat a bacon grilled cheese sandwich.
(Mikhail laughs)
Don't hit the stop button,
unless it's an emergency,
of course, and don't get a
bacon grilled cheese sandwich.
First date, her, I'm really
only interested in inner beauty.
Me, oh I see.
Second date, me, so I
scheduled us for colonoscopies.
That's funny.
That's not the inner
beauty that you wanna see
because I will tell you, unless you do
really good colon prep, which
means drinking that stuff
that makes you clear out, the colon is not
a pretty place to be.
Taming Fred Savage, I don't
know who Fred Savage is.
Me, donating body to science.
Science, donates my body to Goodwill.
That's not how it works.
First of all, everyone should,
highly recommended by me,
become an organ donor.
All the myths out there about
doctors not caring about you
because you're an organ donor,
and they'll let you die,
it's all nonsense, nonsense.
When I'm working in the ER, I have no idea
who's an organ donor, and who's not.
Only once the patient passes
do we even begin to look
for that information,
and we don't donate
the bodies to Goodwill.
I found out it takes 42 muscles to frown,
so I went ahead and
canceled my gym membership.
I don't know it's 42 muscles, but I know
it takes more muscles
to from than to smile.
That's why I'm always
smiling because I'm lazy.
Rodney Lacroix, I wonder
if he owns the water?
Rich?
Doctor, do you exercise?
Me, yes.
Smoke?
No, never.
Drink?
Yes.
How often?
Four kids.
Heavily, got it.
I long and love for those
honest conversations.
As a family medicine doc,
you're talking to someone
who's stressed out.
They're not so excited to
be at a doctor's office
because they have a
million other things to do,
but you just have this
connection where they tell you
about their life, you
understand their struggles,
you help them, you try and make their life
not only a little bit
healthier, but a little bit
more fruitful, so they get more out of it.
They give to the world.
They give to themselves.
Genetics lab, me, one
designer baby please.
Doctor, it's not like that, you.
Me, please remove the
pooping and crying functions.
Doctor, what, no, you can't.
Me, give it wings and flame throwers.
Doctor, hmm?
Me, I'm gonna call her Claire.
(Mikhail coughs)
Sounds like they're building a Transformer
more than they are making a designer baby.
That is literally not how it works.
Your baby will need to cry.
Your baby will need to poop.
In fact, if it didn't
have those functions,
you'll have a bigger problem
with your baby, just saying.
Maybe I took that too seriously.
You know you're a nurse if
you've been telling stories
in a restaurant, and had someone
at another table throw up.
I think that's just being
in the medical profession in general.
Sometimes, I'm telling
stories to my friends,
and they're like, Mike, we're eating,
and I'm like, true.
Poop jokes don't work when
you're eating dessert.
Jessie, doctor, do you exercise?
Me, thinking of the arm
curls to get the chips
from the bag to my mouth.
Yes, daily.
If you actually do a strong
isometric contraction
right here, that could be
exercise, but I don't know
many people who eat chips like that.
If you do, why?
Aunt Chelle, at a doctor appointment,
step up on the scale.
Jokingly, do I have to?
No.
What?
How have I gone this long without knowing
this was an option?
I mean, everything when
you go to a doctor's office
is an option, unless you're
going for a work physical,
or some clearance, but
in general, when you go,
you have a patient bill of rights.
Anything you don't wanna
do, even though we'll try
and recommend why you should
do it, you don't have to.
That's the beauty of medicine.
We work together as a team.
If you're uncomfortable with something,
maybe don't say, I don't wanna do it.
State that you're
uncomfortable, and perhaps,
hear the doctor's explanation
of why it's recommended.
You never realize how
squeaky your shoes are
until you walk into the
room of a sleeping patient,
nurse problems, nurse life.
I don't know what it is,
hospitals are extra echo-y.
Why?
So, I got a text from the
doctor, asking if my crap
was properly hydrated.
Turns out, he actually wrote CPAP, and no,
I'm not adjusting to bifocals.
Well, for those of you who don't know,
CPAP is continuous
positive airway pressure.
It's the thing that people wear
around their nose at night.
It's a big contraption that
lays at the side of their bed.
It basically keeps your airway open
so that when you have sleep apnea,
your airway doesn't collapse,
and you wake up snoring
because you actually weren't breathing.
It's not so comfortable to wear,
but I will say there are
things on the horizon
to make this whole process a lot smoother.
Me, I feel like a pizza party should refer
to pizzas having a party.
Oh wow.
Humans having pizza at
a party should just be
a party with pizza.
Does that make sense to you?
Therapist, I think we
should meet more often.
(Mikhail laughs)
I think that is natural curiosity
that makes you eccentric,
and fun, and interesting to be around.
Matty MSN, you know
it's gonna be a #badday
when the scrub machine gives
you two pants and no shirt.
It's going shirtless.
For those of you who don't know,
there are now Scrub X machines.
I forgot the name of the brand,
where you literally punch
in your employee ID,
or scan your badge, and
it feeds you your scrubs
for the day, and you can
put them on, but sometimes,
they make mistakes, and
they give you wrong sizes,
sometimes it gives you
two pants and no shirt,
and that's a struggle
because to get it fixed,
you need to go find
someone, and if you're busy,
and it's a shift.
Hey, do you wanna hang out?
Sure, I'm free October 32, 2051.
Let's plan something for
then, med student problems.
Oh my God.
I remember when I was on the ICU block,
and I would be working six days a week,
call queue two, which
means every other day,
means you come in at 5
a.m., you leave at 9 p.m.
every other day.
Just imagine how brutal that is.
You have to wake up at 3:30,
4, get to the hospital,
work all day, get home at night,
wake up again super early,
all you did was work and
sleep during the ICU block.
Your friends were like, where did you go
this last month, and you're like, ICU.
They're like, you see me?
No, no, no, I-C, intensive care unit.
Jay Kay, oh, get it, J-K?
Nine out of 10 doctors recommend a diet
rich in lean protein and vegetables,
and one out of 10 doctors is a stakeholder
in the bariatric sleeve.
For those of you who
don't know, by the way,
bariatric sleeve is a
surgery that you can get
in order to shrink the
size of your stomach,
which basically encourages you to not eat,
so you lose a lot of weight quickly.
Other names for this is a stomach bypass,
stomach stapling
procedure, gastric bypass,
all sorts of names, but these
types of bariatric surgeries
actually have really good
evidence working long-term
for those who are really obese,
I'm not talking about if you're
10, 15 pounds overweight.
I'm talking morbid
obesity where the obesity
is presenting an imminent
threat to your life.
CT scan, patient, doc,
you're sure this is safe?
Just a little radiation, right?
Me, from a mile away, behind
some bulletproof glass,
a wall that's 45 feet thick,
and a full suit of lead,
uh-huh, please hold still.
No, look, CT scans absolutely expose you
to a dose of radiation.
The benefits of getting
a CT scan in an emergency
or when there's a true medical condition
that we're trying to evaluate
are outweighed by the risks,
meaning that it's more
beneficial to do the scan,
and expose yourself to
some potential radiation.
That being said, doing
CT scans unnecessarily
is really bad, and as a
patient, okay, you'll get
one CT scan, but as the doctor or the tech
that's doing the exam, you're
doing dozens of these a day,
so you'd be exposed to a ton of radiation,
so you better get 45 feet
away, by a 45-foot wall
with a suit of lead.
Doctor, how do you practice self-care?
Me, pillows.
Doctor, pillows, by sleeping on them?
Me, no, by screaming into them.
You know what?
I wouldn't even judge.
If one of my patients
came in and they said
they get a lot of happiness,
or their emotions out
by screaming into a
pillow, that's awesome.
I think I get a lot of my anger out
and work out my issues when
I'm punching a punching bag,
you know, and to each their own.
There is a surprising
lack of YouTube videos
detailing how to perform self-surgeries
for inguinal hernia.
Yeah because you shouldn't
perform surgery on yourself.
It's really that simple.
There was a story of a
doctor who performed surgery
on themselves in, I think, Antarctica
because there was no access to medicine,
and he performed an
appendectomy on himself.
I'm gonna tell the story in a video
because it's a crazy story,
and you gotta hear it.
If you're down, let me
know in the comments.
No idea Daddy blog, five-year-old,
where's the scissors?
Me, five-year-old, I'm playing doctor.
Hmm, cute.
On the dog.
Takes back scissors.
Bear, that one was about you.
I would never use scissors on you.
You sleepy?
He's a sleepy Bear today.
Look at him.
Look at his little head.
Whoa, that's an aggressive neuf.
(light music)